is there a higher calling than carrying
cancer the attempts that we're making to
cure cancer are really addressing one of
the most challenging problems that
humans face the coming together of
individuals to take on these complex
challenges is our highest calling
[Music]
oh gosh look at this one mark you
remember this look at the kids they're
making their animal claws because my mom
had cancer when I was 14
it had a really strong effect on me I
was very afraid that I would get breast
cancer I just was too afraid to ever go
to the doctor but I felt like I needed
to make sure I was healthy to be there
for the rest of the family I did go and
have a mammogram done my doctor called
me two days later when they had the
results and told me that it was positive
for breast cancer I had the bilateral
mastectomy chemotherapy I thought I've
done it I'm okay
in March of 2018 I woke up at 3 a.m. and
felt a lump right next to my belly
button had two small spots on my lung
and three small spots that were they
could see on an MRI in my brain it felt
like a death sentence I don't sugarcoat
it that's what it felt like I I thought
it would be dead in a few months I
literally just went to that I went to
that spot
they were in the process of getting
ready to open a clinical trial it seemed
like a lifeline in the past we have
treated almost all patients with a given
cancer the same way
yep for many patients those drugs were
not effective precision oncology is
tailoring our therapy to what is
happening in each patient and their
tumor the smart program is the
implementation of precision oncology for
the individual patient we measure the
tumors in many different ways in order
to get clues about how they might be
more effectively attacked this generates
many terabytes of data one of the key
challenges that we have is the need to
analyze that data in real time the
partnership with micron is designed to
make this happen faster using the
technologies that they have available we
are helping the unite Cancer Institute
speed up their analytics pipeline using
microns deep learning accelerators so
that the data extraction is in a
clinically relevant time frame some of
these patients don't have three months
to wait for an analysis to be completed
they need it done in a week in a day an
hour I have been treating patients for a
very long period of time and all too
frequently the cancer wins
however Beth was one of those exciting
cases that when we first analyzed what
was happening with her tumor we knew
that we had something truly exciting for
her the best I thought I was gonna hear
was it hadn't gotten worse I had never
dreamed that the tumors would be reduced
and that there would be nothing new
you build technologies to do something
so why not build the technologies that
will accelerate insight for some of our
most complex questions like cancer I
feel incredibly lucky right now we've
spent time with our grandkids our
seven-year-old we decided to surprise
her for her last day of kindergarten she
jumped up and down and came running out
and went cram he granted me you're here
it was it was the best it was so
wonderful it was those moments I got to
have
[Music]